Battle not with monsters lest you
become a monster. in Batman Beyond I
played an older Bruce Wayne
he still had hope for the world I can
barely walk let alone wear that again
this Bruce Wayne he's become so broken
and so embittered by life that he sees
no hope for the world the first I knew
more a different kind of suit lifetime
of injuries the point of this
exoskeleton is to support his body
because he's been so beaten and broken
that he would not be able to stand up
without it and then they turn it on and
I know I never thought I'd get a chance
to do it on camera because I was getting
older and older and older I was sort of
aging out of Batman you know but
luckily I aged into older Batman
see for yourself I can barely walk a
let alone, wear that again. you understand how many people how many worlds are going to
die well if they're anything like this
world maybe that's for the best. no hope
for this one. because you killed Superman
this guy's not a paragon of anything I
was right we can't trust the monitor
what did you do
clearly what you couldn't. how was he a
threat strange visitor from another
planet comes to earth with powers and
abilities far beyond those of mortal men
Clark. Clark always said yes anyone with
the badge or a flag he gave them too
much power my parents taught me a very
different lesson life only makes sense
if you force it
Kate?
welcome back everyone it's Charlie so
they dropped a new crisis on Infinite earths
Batman video for Kevin Conroy's
Batman I was so happy that he did the
crossover there was a bunch of Easter
eggs during his scene there was even a
big Batman V Superman scene of all
things obviously a lot of the Easter
eggs were for Batman Beyond and the
Batman stuff that he's done like Batman
the Animated Series so we'll break it
all down we'll do a new round of that
flash ring giveaway to that we're doing
for a crisis on Infinite Earths all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your best theory for how it's
going to end I love how he says that he
got too old to play regular Batman but
now he's aged into older Batman because
we all want to see a live-action Batman
Beyond TV series and he would be amazing if Michael Keaton is never going to do a
Batman Beyond movie they reached out to a lot of different versions of Superman
and Batman to try and get them to come
back obviously Michael Keaton said no
but they did try to get Nicolas Cage to
come back as Superman from the Superman
movie that he almost did with Tim Burton
so many years ago that was the crazy
Superman lives movie there are all these
costume tests that are floating around
so you can actually see Nicholas Cage
wearing the suit himself he did finally
get a chance to play Superman but it was
the animated Superman that appeared
during the Teen Titans go movies shear
the reason why most of this Batman stuff
during crisis though for Kevin Conroy
was Batman and Beyond is because there
on earth 99 that's the year that Batman
Beyond started obviously Kevin Conroy is
referencing a lot of that during his
little trailer here but he has two
really big notable lines of dialogue one
of them is from a very notable Batman V
Superman scene my parents taught me a
different lesson is this scene right
here
I bet your parents touched you mean
something it sure here for a reason my
parents taught me different less dying
in the gutter for always at all
so they're kind of trying to imply that
this older version of Batman who's
wearing the Kingdom Come Batman harness so obviously there's a lot of Kingdom
Come references is that he's a version
of Batman from a similar reality to
Batman V Superman where he really did
wind up going the distance the whole way
and killing his version of Superman
the other big quote that he has though
where he says battle not with monsters
is actually part of a larger quote that
says battle not with monsters lest he
become a monster and if you gaze into
the abyss the abyss gazes into you
that's actually a Nietzsche quote is not
from any Batman movie but based on some of the other things that this version of
Batman says like maybe it's better that
this version of earth gets wiped by the
big crisis wave he does kind of sound
like a nihilist version of Batman so why
wouldn't he be quoting Nietzsche and
also sort of tips his hand about his
backstory before you see the trophy case
like he's trying to say that I battled
monsters and I became a monster the
camera doesn't pan around everywhere it
doesn't allow you see everything that's
in this room but all these things are
easter eggs in the background the
confirm kills the one you do see in the
trophy case are the Riddler's broken
cane a glass jar of snow for mr. freeze
right in front of that even though it's
kind of part of spot is the Penguins
umbrella Superman's glasses obviously the Joker's
playing card a plant in a jar for poison
ivy in two phases coin there's a bunch
of other stuff in that trophy case too
but the camera doesn't allow you to see
what it is when you're inside the
Batcave though there's some Easter eggs
in the background you made out of
spotted the first time there's the
Michael Keaton Batmobile from Batman
1989 underneath the tarp you can see it
silhouette is very identifiable in this
console here that they're standing in
front of is from the 1966 Adam West
Batman TV series they're trying to say
that he's the darkest timeline amalgam
version of Batman not including the
Batman who laughs who is from the
darkest of dark timelines because he's
from the dark multiverse maybe someday
they'll do some sort of dark multiverse
big crossover story I feel like that's
one of the few places you can go after
doing crisis on Infinite Earths like you
go to the dark multiverse maybe they can
somehow rope in the new Green Lantern TV show they can work up to a blackest
night there would be my other biggest
pick but speaking of Batman Beyond TV
shows there were a lot of people that
saw this an
shall seem from the very first episode
of crisis on Infinite Earths where they
go to earth 89 which is obviously an
easter egg for Batman 1989 Michael
Keaton's Batman movie you see him in a
newspaper being read by the actor who
played Alexander Knox playing his
character during the crossover from that
original Batman movie but the Batman
signal is very different it's not
Michael Keaton's Batman signal now the
entire multiverse is about to come under
attack there is a malevolent force at work one
driven by a singular goal there were a
lot of people that thought that that's
actually supposed to be for Batman and
beyond
but it's not quite the right shape for
Batman beyond the wings are just a
little bit different so I think it's
just something that they had to come up
with on the fly because for whatever
reason they weren't allowed to use
Michael Keaton's bat signal no idea why
they would do it that way but if you go
to a convention and you have the
opportunity maybe you could ask them
usually it's just like a technical thing
with licensing and they have to pay a
lot of money to use stuff and they
didn't give them a lot of extra money
for little things like that but if you
guys didn't know crisis on Infinite
Earths part 4 is going to air middle of
January though do part 5 because it's
going to be the arrow episode that's part 4 then legends of tomorrow part 5 and then
that's it they just did the first three
episodes before the break I just did a
trailer video for part 4 so I'll link
that at the end of this but it has all
of her as the Spectre with his new
powers talking to Barry about the plan
you're in the Speed Force Barry monitors
the dawn time
he's extremely powerful the eight of us
might not be enough Oliver Queen has now
become the specter of the arrowverse
making him one of the most powerful
cosmic characters that we've ever seen
on the show his job is literally to
punish people for God so they turned the
metaphor of what his character and his
mission has been for the last eight
seasons as the green arrow into a
literal cosmic thing there was some
funny tweets that he was sending out
early in the crossover to about the
number of people that he kills in part
four and part five of the crossover he
didn't say which episode he just said
later in the crossover will wind up
happening those there'll be a couple
more promos that they'll drop so there's
anything really big I will totally do a
video for it but if there's any bonus
videos for the DC stuff or a crisis on
Infinite Earths that you guys want me to
do just let me know in the comments
it'll be a couple weeks through the
holidays before everything comes back
but they'll still be a bunch of stuff
and I'll be posting videos every day so
as long as you have alerts enabled for
my channel you'll see all that stuff
when I post it there's a bunch of
Mandalorian stuff coming up The Witcher
Netflix just dropped with Henry Cavill
Superman himself so if you're big henry
cavill fan i would recommend you check
that out and i also just started posting
which are Netflix videos for those of
you that are wondering when he's going to
be Superman again and when they're going to  do Man of Steel 2 he did say that his
Witcher job with Netflix will not
prevent him from being Superman in
future Superman movies so don't worry
about that but congratulations K Dan Lee
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big DC video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your contact details
everyone click here for the Superman
red Son movie trailer and click here for
my brand new Mandalorian episode 7 video thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight!